so much of parenting is just receding
into the background in those moments and
providing them the space so that they
can indulge their creativity yeah and
carrying the stuff you know like Vinnie
has said that to somebody recently you
know you don't need to buy your kid a
three thousand dollar guitar you know
you they don't need that you know what
it what can you do you can help them
haul their stuff into the car and haul
them stuff out at the band practice or
whatever you've done that so many times
right yeah it's like you're just hauling
it like making sure they get there you
know yeah it's allowing it and not not
kind of over pushing it you know a lot
of people I think they're like oh my kid
is interested in this so the next day
they have my parenting moment yes my
parenting moment they're going to have a
classical guitar lesson they're going to
have a three thousand dollar guitar and
they can have this like yeah it doesn't
have to be that you know because also
that's a lot of pressure for kids